Nguyễn Ngay quan, chuyến thông thái lan không chỉ lưỡ tiền đậm ngay về đại hội mối bốn của đàn công sản Việt Nam mà còn nếu bật vị thay và định hướng của nước ta trên yếu lĩnh vực.
Bỏ mạng trai pop lịch khác của thái lan đăng bài viết với tiêu đề, đại hội đề biểu tân cúc lần thứ mối bốn của đàn công sản Việt Nam,
bân ngoặt đưa đất nước, bước vào kiểu quế mởi, khẳng đế hội là một bân ngoặt chính lợch trong kinh trình hẹn đại hóa được phản định bài bản và có tâm dình dài hạc của Việt Nam.
Thế bài viết, quy mô tổ chứ cùng công tất chuyện bị công phong, chú thái tâm quan trọng đọc biệt của sự kẹn chính trị này.
Thái pháp lịch khác cũng cho rằng, sợ quan tâm ngày càng lớn của công đồng của tảy đưa thể hiện qua số lượng phóng viên nước ngoài,
đang tí tăng nghiệp đông gạo và việc Việt Nam chủ đọc tiêu đọc tiêu đọc trung tâm báo chỉ có tệ tự sớm,
đều mối bốn đường đánh xá là giống mốt cho thấy sự chuyện gì gọn này, sang môi hình tăng trường mối, tập trung vấn đề càng năng sớt,
tuại số quá, và chính thịt xanh và tăng nghiệp có giả trị ra tăng cao, đồng thời gần mạnh tại cái chiếc trên nhiều liên bực.
Chúng kì đảo bảo, Brad Chân Child, Buzzナe s đăng kại phỏ vấn của giò s healthcare,
tiếng Xe, Mr. Hộ Röc Th rug, Phu Mi, vlog, Trên gia, Việt Nam, phân tích các bạn để tình thể trao nghiệm tại đợh biến bốn,
và sau sang triển và phát triển với Việt Nam và Thái Lan.
Bàn những định Việt Nam đang tăng trưởng gành nhé nhiều sức khủ và thú đẹp đẹp đi,
sang vẫn đối mặt thích các vầy chức định của nguyên lượng.
Mọi gia như các quan truyền thông lớn khác của Thái Lan như Banh Khu Pauce, Thái Raph, PPTV và Delaney Scouro Đông Ngạt Lưu Thin,
Đánh Xe Kháu Đình Vũn Cái Cách, mục tiêu tăng trường và thông địa phát triển mạnh mẽ được nếu tài đại hội mối bốn của đạn cục sản Việt Nam.